un président la campagne à défaut d'être
officiellement déjà en campagne en
haute-saône emmanuel macron assure le
service après-vente du plan
d'investissement france relance dont
bénéficie ce refuge spa 23000 euros des
de bienvenue afin d'améliorer les
infrastructures on est prêt mais des
liens mais même avec des êtres comme ça
bahia tous trois fait à gré emmanuel
macron annonce un nouvel effort
financier de l'état au profit des
refuges et une enveloppe pour aider les
retouches car doubler et puis est vénale
de 5 millions plus pour vraiment aider
aux opérations de stérilisation toutes
les associations qui le font parce que
ses médecins lui nombreux lots le
président de la république salue
également l'investissement des nombreux
bénévoles du refuge
il leur a promis que la loi sur la
maltraitance animale règlement très
bientôt davantage la vente des chiens et
des chats
pour les gens s'engagent quand ils
achètent faut limiter des achats sur des
sites où on pouvait en un clic la voir
et puis on livrait à domicile comme si
c'était un jouet donc tout ça là les
parlementaires sont en train de
travailler il ya une loi qui va passer
pour empêcher tout ça
critiqué par les associations de défense
des animaux qui dénoncent ses positions
pro chasse et son supposé manque
d'ambition pour limiter les abus de
l'élevage intensif emmanuel macron se
présente ici comme le chantre du
bien-être animal tout le monde est
attaché à la condition animale personne
ne veut qu'ils aient des pratiques qui
soient cruel qui ne correspondent plus à
la manière dont nous voyons les animaux
en même temps nos compatriotes sont
attaché à la ruralité et à des
traditions on a trop tendance à opposer
les mondes dans notre pays les chasseurs
se sont des acteurs de la ruralité un
chasseur il aime son chien il aime les
animaux et la nature sinon ils feraient
pas de la chasse défendre la cause
animale tout en défendant les chasseurs
et leurs méthodes traditionnelles 1 en
même temps typiquement macro niant tout
sauf un hasard à six mois de l'élection
présidentielle